ten strikeouts the last time for you
noah on this mound in atlanta and he's
facing an arizona club look we may not
know much about them one thing we do
know they can hit they just had a great
series against cincinnati hemio2 is cut
on and missed ball in the dirt the
diamondbacks will concede the out and
that will retire the side three up three
down luke weaver to the hill for the
snakes next luke weaver
dominated the reds and flirting with
that no hitter at chase field
but over the weekend in washington took
the loss lasted only four it is
sends this one out to cole calhoun and a
nice quick one two three first for luke
weaver no score in atlanta on valley
sports
well kelly's been hurting the baseball
to 351 mark 10 rbis
part of the big haul arizona got when
they traded paul goldschmidt to st louis
this one's lifted to the right side foul
ground freeman near the netting takes a
peek reaches out man he got it what a
catch by freddie freeman over the
railing and kelly and the diamondbacks
pop out to retire the side freddie
freeman's got a gold glove you know and
he showed it off there played the ball
very well the 0-1
popped up along the left-field line long
run coming over as peralta still coming
can't get there it's fair ball
a foot inside the chalk after a long run
ozzy albies has himself a double
you know what it almost looks like ozzy
was trying to do that and now alby's at
second still with two outs
and austin reilly is the battery two on
pitch
fly ball well hit towards center smith
on the run warning trap
it's two nothing atlanta
he's seeing the ball well now he's
starting to get the ball in the air jeff
and that's real good news yeah it's
great news
we keep talking about this braves lineup
needing to be lengthened like it was
last year
as you said going up there there's
chapman like that walking you saw the
home run he hit yankee stadium wednesday
night
[Applause]
it's a confident hitter
took that change up dead center no balls
two strikes or noah live drive there it
is a base hit that's headed for the
corner peralta's got a really hustle to
the wall
as he noah will
make his way in his second with a
stand-up double
[Applause]
yeah he wants to mix it up first career
hit
[Applause]
[Music]
i've had a few now right
ian had his first hit yep
kyle wright had his first hit yep
we don't need to stink in d.h
between our pitchers and our our bench
great stuff
lined back through the box skips off the
mound swans with a great pick up from
center field throws to first and got him
what a play
skipped off the mound dansby ranging to
his left in the outfield grass
made a sensational stop with quick hands
and then a quick release to first into
one two three
[Applause]
wow
a couple of outstanding defensive plays
in this game
ready a native of cuba
3-2
swing and a shot hammered toward left
peralta going back
it's over his head and off the wall
heredia flying towards second to throw
is late
a line drive double off the left field
fence for her radio
his second two base hit of the year boy
that ball jumped off the bat he just
missed the home run here by about two
feet but that's what you do chip you
fell off a couple you see what six seven
pitch of that ab
austin's behind in the count shift on
for riley the one-two pitch
driven toward right
calhoun headed toward the foul line
still going near the stands dives into
the stands and can't come up with it hey
that fan made a great catch
yeah knuckles why not
love it
he's looking cole he's impressed
yeah fist bumps all around great catch
never left his seat
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh that's great
so jackson's gonna be intentionally
walked they'll go ahead and bring inoa
to the plate and try to put out this
atlanta rally in the fourth inning noah
by the way who doubled last time up is
the hitter
yeah just do it again
line drive base head how about that
coming to third he's coming home
peralta's throw is up the first base
line inoah is two for two and look at
kevin seitzer
let's go
i know we joke about a chip but
look help yourself out
and remember the pitch before
might have been a strike yeah it wasn't
called one the swing on the house you
know it took advantage heredius slides
home and the braves add to the lead it's
now three to nothing
carson this year has an on base
percentage
of
37 here's the 3-1
he swings and clubs one to deep left
ozuna going back to the fence it is gone
carson kelly with a two-run home run
into the left-field bullpen and the
d-backs are on the board they've cut it
to three to two
boy four-seam fastball it was up in the
zone only at 93 miles an hour
but carson just jumped on it and again i
think that's a product of taking some
pitches getting something you can slug
and he nails it that was a high fastball
we've seen carson do that a few times in
his career get on top of a high fastball
like that
and drive it home run number five for
kelly the inning continues with ozuna at
second and swanson coming up
fly ball headed for the gap in left
center field nobody's getting it
dansby comes through with a big two out
hit he's around second helmet flying
he's headed for third half belly flop in
with a big time triple
another two out run for the braves
all four of them tonight they extend the
lead it's a good pitch and splits that
gap shows that speed with the ball
getting just stuck under there
running all the way and gets a triple
two outs runners at the corners d-max
down 4-2 here's josh rojas
rojas down the line that's in the corner
and
fair peralta's home here comes eduardo
they're going to stop him at third
josh rojas makes it 4-3 boy josh rojos
he was upset with himself earlier in it
he felt like he missed a slide or he
should have done some damage with it
looked a lot like that one
patrick ready with his 3-2 pitch
here it is
straw came out with a high heat
boy do the braves need that
arizona settles for one the braves still
have the lead as we send you to the
stretch in our atlanta studios no balls
in a strike
fly ball wallop down the line did he
keep it fair
that's great too into the chop house
that ball exploded off the bat of ozzy
albee's his third homer yeah one of the
second deck of the chop house talking
about getting ozzy going now two extra
base hits tonight double
and a huge home run just to give you
one more run and give you a little bit
of room
smith gets the lead from third even
creeping down the line
the payoff madison takes ball four in
the dirt it gets away from jackson and
smith's gonna come home and score smith
ready again with his 0-2 pitch
[Applause]
back to the mound
a good throw seals the deal and the
braves win game one 5-4 your final